peu
[Musique]
c'est la révélation du festival
arrangements voix et santé christine
fais tout toute seule sur scène vrai
coup de coeur musical c'est pas de danse
font craquer plus d'un
[Musique]
un serre tête en forme de boîte de
rennes pour son côté bête de chaîne
[Musique]
je souligne souvent le fait que je
travaille seul parfois c'est un peu un
reproche quand on me dit par exemple
parce que tu penses un jour quand même
finir par avoir un groupe on sent que
c'est un petit reproche mais on le
souligne beaucoup parce que déjà je
pense que c'est pas tout c'est pas
quelque chose de très évident de
proposer un projet musical sans groulx
avec un ordinateur et de beaucoup
[Musique]
maintenant je suis tellement habituée à
porter ce projet seul
que je me dis que c'est devenu aussi que
je suis devenu un peu le groupe que je
n'ai pas eu que je me suis fait aussi à
moi même et je pense que j'en aurai un
deux groupes
si je rencontre les bonnes personnes qui
leur donnerait envie de faire un fromage
[Musique]
et on sait
ma curité dans la voix mélodie
pénétrante texte en anglais des cas les
puissants d'une bretonne vivant à nantes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
christine redonne du glamour et des
paillettes au monde défaut x
[Musique]
m